a cattle ranch in central Bolivia in
recent years raising livestock like
cattle has become one of the fastest
growing economic sectors in this part of
the country
every year we are exporting more and
more livestock products like meat and
milk it has grown fivefold over the last
15 years and that is because we have
been well positioned to do so
Mauricio cerrate a third generation
cattle rancher says this current
agricultural boom has a lot to do with a
growing diversification of the national
economy as the country moves away from
an over-reliance on exports of
hydrocarbons like Natural Gas
over the past decade Bolivian gas
production has plummeted dragging with
it what was formally termed Bolivia's
economic Miracle a period of notable
economic growth at the turn of the
century that witnessed years of
government spending led by former
Bolivian president Evo Morales which
lifted millions of people out of poverty
in the past Bolivia was a net energy
exporter gas was its main export product
nowadays that entire sector is in
Decline and we are increasingly
importing Diesel and gasoline
though Bolivia holds abundant lithium
reserves a mineral coveted by technology
companies around the world experts say
the government has struggled to attract
the necessary foreign investment
economists point to these as some of the
main factors driving the rise of the
Agricultural sector
Agro businesses like this cattle ranch
are the driving engine of the Bolivian
economy products like soybean and beef
have become leading exports with China
and Europe representing some of the most
important International markets
though many in Bolivia worry over slow
economic growth in the post-pandemic era
the export of grains meat and milk
products sourced in the country's
agricultural Heartland has proven to be
the Bolivian economy's most valuable
secret weapon Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera
Santa Cruz Bolivia
prisoners in Ecuador have released
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera